what is the biggest challenge that women
are facing these days what's the biggest
problem that you're seeing in the
not
manufacturing terms is that even a thing
you want to start with go yeah i think
women have immense pressure from every
side pulling on them i think they have
the expectation to be highly educated to
be highly independent independent from
men to rollo's point to be uh to be hot
uh to be friendly to prioritize their
family all of these different things i
think it's it's it's a lot of different
things that are pulling on women they
did a study they found out that 56 of
working women uh who have kids 18 and
under would have preferred to stay home
had been given the option right say
those numbers again 56
of working women with kids more than
half of women would have preferred to
stay home if given the option so i think
there's something to women that like man
by the and jordan peterson made the
quote the point of uh the biggest fall
off in terms of women leaving is in the
in executive law when you start getting
to higher levels of law women check out
because if i'm married to a lawyer which
most lawyers are married to other
lawyers 200k a year versus 300 500k the
lifestyle change isn't that much
different they don't go to college to
find a husband anymore they get a law
degree to find a husband now so they so
they exit out of that field so i think
there's so many different pressures on
women to to figure these things out um
and i think some education is good i
think it's good to be educated i think
it's good to have some skills uh but i
think if your entire mentality is like
i'm gonna be this bad independent chick
that's gonna run everything uh most men
don't want that from most women most men
want a wife that's flexible most men one
and wife that will let them lead most
men want a wife that's in fit healthy
you know and that that is okay with and
again there's outliers there's outliers
in situations there's entrepreneurial
women that are incredible and they're
crushing it and there's this there's
outliers but most men also probably
would want the woman to raise the kids
and stay home with the kids and we've
done that uh my wife came home 2014
right when we had our first kid and uh
and she's been home ever since she works
from home she does some stuff she does
all of our accounting um but i think
that's still a very healthy model and
they've done the studies i told you this
you know the the
family with two incomes nets less than
the family one bread winner which again
goes back to financial independence if
as a man you can provide i think you
position yourself to be in a much more
happy marriage a stable marriage joyful
marriage and so i think there's a lot of
pressure man and i would just say who
are you pulling from and who do you want
to be same point rollo you talk about
this all the time that men don't really
care what women make because they don't
share their money with men now well the
number one precipitator of divorce is
when a couple is making the same amount
of money and the woman gets like a raise
and pay she gets a promotion at work or
she is boosted into a status and also a
monitor it gets makes more money than
the guy does that marriage is the number
one perspective
or single or working women doomed for a
um a a a lifetime of sadness because
they're chasing the money yes yes you
are just yes you are you're doomed to a
lifetime statistically speaking uh
morgan not me career working woman are
just working
exactly career is like this is my
priority a man will come later kids will
come later a girl working and she's like
i gotta pay my bills yeah there's a
difference between a job and a career
for women exactly and and the other i
should also add this is that like we
have sold and i agree with you here it's
like we have sold women a bill of goods
really since the sexual revolution that
you can have it all baby right you don't
you don't need a man you might want a
man but you don't need them you don't
even need a man to reproduce go down to
the sperm bank go down to the fertility
clinic you can have a you don't even
have to do that now you can go on
facebook and find a sperm donor if you
want to you literally can do that but uh
so we have essentially you want to talk
about like making things convenient for
women uh in that sense we have said what
what you we made men superfluous right
now uh whether you're a father or
whatever until it's like you know
father's day and it's like do better dad
kind of thing but we've made guys
superfluous in the sense that like women
don't see any point of getting with a
guy who is either going to be an abuser
he's going to be a doofus like homer
simpson he's going to be incompetent
yeah we teach women that men are
untrustworthy that they are that you
can't depend on them for security the
number one thing and this happened with
with you and and
if they cheat well
you just did what i was just about to
say i thought hold up that's what i was
about to say quick pull put this up
there for our gentleman out there um
would you rather have a more of a
housewife traditional woman or do you
want a woman who's out there making
money if you could put that poll out
there i'd love to see the results
you just said housewife or what
housewife or working woman natalia you
just made my case for me okay when ally
was on here and she did that one viral
video
yeah she was talking about it yeah when
she was talking about like i'm a
traditional wife i submit to my husband
blah blah the number one complaint i
mean it went viral 4 million god knows
how high it was the number one complaint
from women was i would never want to do
that because what if he left what if he
started banging his secretary what if he
got a trophy wife what if what if what
if what if and it was all based on fear
as i said fear is the most monetizable
emotion of that huma
to be fair though men are statistically
more likely to cheat than women yes true
but the thing is we've terrorized
generations of women with the idea that
if you don't have a career if you don't
have this this will happen to you and
what happens is that fear is based on
what's called the apex fallacy so what's
the alternative though like you you're
against no fault divorce laws and you're
against uh
alimony you're against a man a man
marrying a woman alimony is alimony by
the way is a law that is a holdover it's
a vestige from the 1930s from the
depression era sure
yeah i don't know how that's relevant
but what i'm saying is if we have men
who are leaving women my dad left my mom
we were on welfare i know we talked
about the welfare state like it's the
sexy thing it was
fifty 650 a month real sexy six hundred
fifty dollars a month our rent was four
hundred fifty dollars a month i remember
that as a kid as a kid we'd go without
food and my dad didn't pay a whole lot
of child support he was like 90 bucks a
month when he did pay and again props to
my dad i love my dad now we're good uh
and i got to see some of his perspective
on the other but what about like when
men are hypergamous what about when men
abandon women i've cause i've seen that
they've seen that that is the only
narrative you hear that is absolutely
the only narrative you hear is the
deadbeat dad like you for instance like
we in fact we especially every father's
day we it's not father's day anymore
it's a special person's day right now it
is
that's not something but every but ever
you can you can do a thing you can get
this in every church sermon if you look
at the difference between mother's day
sermons and father's day sermons
mother's day is oh you're do you're
doing great girl you we love you so much
you do you're doing the job of t you
know ten men yeah and they don't you
don't need no and no man you're doing
you're just as good a father as you are
as a mother when father's day rolls
around the sermon is do better just do
better because you're you're not living
up to your expectations that it's
constantly like
isn't that a more masculine way to like
get men to react that's why they're not
that's why they're not in a church right
what do you what would you tell a
natalia or you said you have a 24 year
old daughter the young women out there
that are listening
what would you what would your advice be
for them as far as like working we
talked you made the distinction between
having a god is a phd student no well no
she's got a master's she's good but i
mean and she's getting married right the
difference between a career and a job
and advice for women well so my point is
this is like i don't have a problem like
people say we talked about this on jedi
again we were talking about the repeal
the 19th you know should we take away
women's right to vote i don't believe
that we should i think that i mean
that's a thing now well it's been that
way for a long dude
welcome to the mgtow who's advocating
for that doom pill black pill big towers
so here's my point i always think okay
number one that's untenable like that's
never going to happen period because
women are the largest voting bloc in the
united states now
but beyond that point is should women
have the right to vote right should they
be the ones that are making decisions
politically you can talk about you know
what what is a vote and what's not a
vote as far as like you know
understanding electoral process but the
thing is this is that um i don't i'm not
against women participating in in the
government i'm not i'm not interested i
don't care like what as far as
access to opportunity i hope my daughter
has equal access to opportunity that she
wants however and i have told her this
is that you are also responsible for the
results of your decisions because right
now up to this point really since the
sexual revolution women have wanted to
live with the benefits of old order
privileges of being a woman with new
order with new order privileges of also
you know having having been being a
woman so you have all of these you have
this this decision to go and and marry
who you want to but guess what that
might have been the wrong choice for you
or abortion for that matter as well it's
like you had sex with this guy and uh
you know now you have the baby and it's
you it's not his decision to abort the
baby it's your decision it's not about
what happened before that it's about you
get to decide whether that child lives
or dies that right there
is a result of this idea that we can
forgive women of their of their uh their
absolve them of the bad decisions so
that they have a fail safe in many
different ways abortion happens to be a
fail safe but it's also i it's not that
i don't think women should have choice
they need to own the results and the
consequences of those choices and right
now we don't do that there's a separate
standard of justice for women so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]